Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at Candy's 3
Now we're continuing on with the second night
We survived the first one
It was only the rat then and there
Am I back here, hello?
So how did it go?
Oh, wonderfully.
You managed to beat them? Awesome job!
Wait, was it only the Monster Rat?
I thought there'd be more!
Phew, but don't celebrate yet
Those monsters are very persistent
He will probably come back even stroooonger
But don't be scared
Remember the strategy from last night
Then everything should be fine!
You already have your stuff, so...
If you want to, you can skip the deepscape
And go to sleep right away
There's still stuff out there to be discovered
If you feel like playing detective, that is
Okay! I'll go out. I like playing detective.
My old dresser.
I've got nothing else to say about that
It is my dresser and only that and nothing else
Okay then, I guess I'm going into the dreamscape.
Hello!
Beware of the shadows
Okay, I already knew about that
Ah, no. I'm good, okay
Schubuduboopboopboobooboop
I know where I am going
Ooo, hello
Do not be afraid of stepping slightly
Ah, this is the same messages as before
huh
So...
Is it like the dreamscape is the same opening
And reminds you of the same things
But it's still slighty different
Then it once was
Continue north to reach the path
ehugh
AHHHHHHHHHH
Okay!
Alright!
eeeehYAH!
Oooooooh, hey
I didn't make it
Who'd a thunkeded?
Okay, so maybe if I continue north from here, I'll be okay
Okay
I saw something
Did you guys see that? The black shadow?
oh, okay, alright then
So, hoooow
How?
North towards the path
Halfway through the darkness, turn East
Oh!
Ah! Good.
Incomplete instructions, eh?
That's not East that's West!
AH! Okay.
Found something even though I went the wrong way
Okay, alright then
A part of a newspaper article.
Read it?
Sure!
Experience the show like never before!
With puppeteering technology of the future
The Rat and Cat will take you on a new adventures
To brand new and exciting worlds of fun!
Alrighty then, thank you
Where am I supposed to go now?
AH! Okay
Alright, this time I gotta turn East
But apparently I found an Easter egg
That probably very few people have found
Just because I can't remember my god damn directions
Ah, F**k I didn't go far enough
Alright, let's try this again
Is there anything on the back of here?
East from this rock
Okay, alright then
Ah! God damn it.
Alrighty, then
OH, I saw it!
Oh, I saw it
I almost had that
It's there. It exists there.
How do you get there, though?
SHOOP!
SHOOPTY WOBBLEYWOBBLEYWOBBLEY
Oh! I made it!
Holy shit, I made it.
Okay, so it was possible.
Holy shit
Alrighty, then
Where am I? The road's all fragmented.
Oh, that's not good
That's not good EHY!
Okay, alright
AY (yells)
okay
Alright then
Hello, what are you?
What is this?
Oh, found arcade game number two
Well good for me!
What else is here? Nothing
Alrighty then
Anything else?
Ah! okay, alright then
But I found the arcade game!
So that's good I think
Do I have it still? Probably
Okay, so I found that. So that's good
I don't know what that does for me though
You already have your stuff so...
If you want to, you can skip the deepscape
And go to sleep right away
Still stuff out there to be discovered
If you feel like playing detective
Alright let me go
Let me just make sure that I got it
I'll be right bacK
Yeah I got it I got it, ok I got it
I GOT IT. Heeeyy alright then
Alright so I got that, no need to worry about that
So we can just go right in the uh.. actual night
But that's, that's interesting alright
Let's go to sleep, bye bye everybody
the second night
so hopefully
or unhopefully theres more monsters
waiting for me in the darkness
so I've got to be even more intentive
then i was last time
which should be fun lets see
lets see play my tape
Play,sooth me to sleep with
your sweet lies
AHH! yes, so
comforting in here.
so does that mean the cat is gonna be present
noow,because if it is, i dont know if it is
gonna be any different, the the cat
in my dreams suggested
that it might actually BE
the same,  but I'll still ready to punch
him up his rectum if he even comes
remotely close to me if he is even
coming from the normal ways that than
other one came from why I didn't see
nothing there was it the cat of the rat
who is it the rat in the Hat the cat in
the rat were they doing something the
nursery rhyme I don't want to be part of
Alrighty then,  it's all- come on out
what was that??
hi! okay how- imma just recharge my tape here that's
how it works right? I'm a millennial I
don't get rewinding *weird grunt* whooo's theeeerrree? anybody?
right flip-flopping whoo I heard that
What was that? hoh! hey, alright then! aauuhh shit.
Okay... it's only when I venture into the unknown
*gibberish* I'm a little bit apprehensive
what's going on here *grunting yeah* I'm not
telling my nightmare story I've got a
lot more nightmare stories but- by the
way in case you guys actually wanted to
hear all that like when I say I have
nightmares all the time I am not joking
I have nightmares almost every other
night and a lot of the times I'll have
what are called waking nightmares
where
you wake up but you don't know you're
awake you're still dreaming so you kind
of hallucinate things in your room and
you hallucinate seeing things like in
the shadows and and you're literally
trapped there you can't move because
your body is still frozen and so your
mind is like halfway between dreaming
and reality and that happens to me
quite a lot actually what was that that Hey....okay
all right then gonna rewind gonna be
kind okay so it happens to me a lot like
not as often as the normal nightmares in
general but like that does happen a lot
where I'm I'm just lying in bed after I
have woken up or at least I think maybe
I've woken up at the time it doesn't
feel like it though so usually what
happens is I know there's someone coming
into my room like someone is trying to
get in someone is like taking steps
closer and clo- oh what was that? what was that?
what was that?? HEY! f**king- hi. you were
distracting me is that what you were
doing ah f*ck... oh god okay ah f**k alright. let's play this game squeaky
McSqueakerson! there yet? oh hello different side!... nooooooo okay alright then
shobbity boobie boobie ok gonna play my tape
don't mind me alright so yeah it's
usually like that I'm locked in my body
and I think someone is walking towards
my bed and it may or may not be with the
attention to hurt me or not but someone
in your room that you don't know is just
walking in that's usually bad so that's
usually when I uh-I uh- I start to panic and
the worst thing is you can't move like I
can't move when that happening like I
literally am stuck in bed unable to move
it and like I'm fighting as hard as I
can to be able to move and then suddenly
I'll be free and wake up and I'll like
violently throw myself out of bed and
just like it's one of those moments
where you wake up breathing heavy from a
nightmare but I was living the nightmare
the whole time thinking that someone was
stalking towards my bed it's just as bad
as it sounds those ones actually still
they still scare me Oh
okay hey how's it go all right don't you
God I don't even know how to beat you
with this shit is it even possible I
mean all I'm doing this shining light in
your eyes kind of already was there
looming over my bad all right for ya
buddy boo heard that hello yeah that
happens maybe like once or twice like
once every two months or so is what I'd
say for that one but the normal
nightmares was having all the time yeah
there's even like weirder occasions that
happened a long long time ago I remember
this one that stands out in my memory
much like em much like the that one time
long ago but this is when i was a
teenager probably around i think i was
like 14 maybe i was i was in bed and i
don't remember having a nightmare that
night but I remember waking up in the
middle of the night I woke up for no
apparent reason and when I looked up at
the ceiling it was crawling like the
ceiling was moving I have one of those
textured ceilings you know the stucco
patterns whatever it is so I think it
was just my eyes playing tricks on me
but for some reason and I don't really
know why I got out of bed I got out of
bed and grabbed my notebook oh shit I
didn't remind that hey yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah so I hello who's there hi okay so I
remember I got out of bed and I grab my
notebook and a pencil and i went down
stairs and I kind of just it i I really
don't know why but I i laid down or i
sat down at the base of the stairs in
the darkness and I just stared at the
doorway next to it the hallway entryway
archway and I just stared there and i
SAT there and I couldn't tell if I was
dreaming or not I really couldn't tell
like what I was doing or what was going
on I
just remember our staring at the store
wakes watching it morph and shift and
like change and I would blink and i
would think that something was there
like this is shadow looming in the
hallway like entryway like I don't know
I don't know why I was just sitting
there staring at it and he would go and
it would be there and he would be gone
and then it would come back and it was
just big moving shadow like shifting and
like morphing in the darkness and I knew
I knew at the time it was just my eyes
playing tricks on me and i wasn't really
scared at that point I was kind of
creeped out but I wasn't scared so high
okay alright this fuck you fuck you fuck
you fuck you fuck you fuck you fuck you
fuck you fuck you damn it there's no way
to win that I did pretty good on that
one I think fuck god damn it out ok well
I don't know what that was all about I
don't know what was with that noise but
it covered up any possibility of me
hearing him creak out I don't look done
almost done there i wailed my hand off
my mic stand I damn it haha ok alright
then
whoa I got him to go away holy shit I've
never done that before it's a fuck who
all right fan me I didn't even know if
that was possible but I must have done
good make them my reflexes are getting
better that you go hey yours go back
over there okay so yeah to recap my
story I'm at the bottom of the stairwell
staring into the entryway into the
darkness and I see occasionally like
very occasionally this big moving
shadowy figure just it's kind of like in
the static of the darkness like I just
see the outline of it no details just
arms legs body and head and so I take my
notebook and I just start sketching the
doorway like the whole entryway and I
sketch just trying to get like a picture
of what I saw I'm not a hundred percent
sure why but I was just sitting at the
bottom of the stairwell in the darkness
it was like 3am sketching and then I
can't even see what I'm drawing because
it's so dark so I just kind of get a
rough outline and then I look closely at
what I was drawing and I see what I drew
it I i literally just drew this shadowy
figure standing in the doorway and for
some reason when I did that it made it
really real for me like maybe I was
still dreaming at that point but I was
physically downstairs and so like I sort
of realized where I was and looked
around and I was just like I had this
overwhelming sense of dread like this
isn't a ghost story anything this isn't
anything like that nothing supernatural
happened but this is really what
happened to me and and I had no no
justification for why I was doing that
and why I was down there and why i drew
this shadowy figure in the archway in
the middle of the night like I had
nothing to prove I had nothing to do
there was no reason for me to it I
wasn't ghost hunting
for some reason went downstairs I just
sat in the darkness drawing the shadow
monsters staring back at me oh and that
was the creepiest point I don't even
think i mentioned it I drew eyes like
not real like descriptive eyes I drew I
hold in the thing and I couldn't see
that in the darkness but for some reason
I drew it with eyes I just felt like it
was looking at me and it was horrifying
bullshit hello picking up
okay hard fuck yourself okay oh yeah
from that point on like
like I was shook basically and we didn't
even have that word back then but I was
shook with a capital SH and so I-I
I couldn't go back to my bed because
like the ceiling was still crawling to
me the ceiling was still moving it was
like I was out of the dream finally and
yet the dream was still around me so I
uh we had our golden retriever buddy
they're not chica buddy who's an awesome
dog that you guys are probably seen
videos developing pictures of I i called
the buddy and I just had to go lay on
the couch I couldn't go through that
doorway the archway but I went around it
and it's just like okay I things get
foggy after that I I think like I called
out to Buddy because I didn't want to me
and yeah oh yeah that's my other
nightmare story I've got you go there's
like that oh boy or girl okay hiring
my parents dragged me over here with my
little sister but I'd rather be on my
bike with my friends you're my little
sister by the way fuck you all right
then sure okay lalala why this place so
horrifying as everything's awful in its
place stock costumes aren't even back
convincing i watch the wrap from behind
it be still to defend forward and you
can see this big metal zipper lock Singh
behind his neck I think it was bear to
keep his head from falling off and such
looks pretty uncomfortable to wear felt
like that totally breaks the atmosphere
alrighty then staff area boys only sure
okay there's a bunch of newspaper
clippings it's a poster for the rat and
cat theater they need to advertise in
their own theater do they hello dad is
that you there's my girl ain't any
friends today no not at all everyone he
I don't have to go. that's the boys
restroom okay so that hasn't changed
I'm just wondering when it's gonna start
murdering everybody- whack a mole! please
don't hog the game share with everyone
oh hi your dress looks almost the same
as mine we should be friends okay should
we I'll do that okay okay bye then oh
hey hello there I'm the Cat! do you like
to play games I know I do we have a
couple of minutes before today's show starts.
do you wanna play hide and seek with me? sure hey
you hide and I'll count alrighty then
backstage employees only all right hello
hi did you like to show yesterday I kind
of liked it oh boy I sure can get down
from the quick literal are gaining good
very surprising nice you're surprising
yeah okay all right oh I get it your
birthday you're such a such a rough life
you live kid I'm about to be murdered so
should I hide in the exact same table
that I've just hided in or maybe I could hide
by the table that my dad's at. maybe
that'll be good for me maybe I could hide
in here hide in the closet? HELL YEAH!
heeey! haha nice try i got you! all right then.
that cats good that's real good
okay go anyway that's all the time oh
it's the cat there now that's the cat I
can notice by the cat eyes it's
different so anyway that's the second
episode of five nights at candy's 3
it's getting real good I like it a lot I
uh I believe that the cat is going to be going us in the next one hopefully that's not
going to kill us at least I know now
they'd be is technically possible to get
him to go away if their outfield so
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video. Bye Bye!